- By the way, the only reason
I give away all
my shit for free,
and you know
this is how I roll,
you've benefited from it.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Is 'cause I know
there's only a couple of you.
- [Man] That are gonna do it.
- Bingo.
- [Man] Right. Dude--
- [Gary] I know we're gonna
rant and I don't kinda guests.
Guys, its execution.
- [Man] Right.
- Guys, ready, ready, it's a
good idea to be Ben Affleck,
right, and what's the
other, Matt Damon and
write a great script and
make a movie called
"Good Will Hunting"
become famous,
bang chicks, make lots of
money and have a great life.
That's a good idea.
Good now go do it.
- [Man] Exactly.
- When are we going to
understand that
entrepreneurship is a skill?
When are we going to understand
that look now working hard
working smart, you can get some.
A lot of people listening right
now are making $48,000 a year,
$72,000 a year and could
probably start a business that
makes 200,000 year
and that's great.
But if you do not understand
that it actually is actual
talent that helps
build a 10, 30, 40.
What everybody needs to do on
this that's listening and that
what you and I have to do the
only thing we can really do is
put ourselves in
the best position
to succeed to
maximize our upside.
Let me sing like you know
meet me at the crossroads.
That shit sucks Bone Thugs
knows how to do it like,
yes, yes anybody
can start a business.
- [Man] Right.
- Good. Now what?
- [Man] Right, exactly.